hey guys it's greg alba sitting here
talking to you today and i'm john
sitting here talking to you today sci-fi
wanted us to check out a show that's
called hunters alright so i want to tell
you guys yes they did asked us to check
this out and I'm gonna be honest with
you guys I was like all right I'll watch
it because they're asking us to I wasn't
expecting to honestly walk away like I'm
really going to enjoy this I saw reviews
for it on rotten tomatoes and I was
listening some of the critics reviews
and sounds like think they were basing
off of the first episode and i gotta say
like by the time you get to the second
episode like the first episode really
felt like a pilot to me yeah yeah second
episode really establishes the show in a
much better way visually it looks great
the the practical effects are great the
writing improved the act like it really
felt like after they got the show picked
up that they really improved the show a
lot more once the second episode rolls
around anything that stood out in your
mind is like that's a little rough for
like oh this is a cool idea but you know
by the second episode you're like oh
they addressed all those things this is
interesting cuz like there's a lot of
high concept stuff on network TV and
things like that there are a lot of
different shows with interesting vaguely
sci-fi concepts but this show does seem
like it's interested in the science of
its science fiction so you're learning
about what these what the hunters are
and what their capabilities are and
there's a heavy use of like sound in the
show both as you know it in the actual
way that you hear it but also as a
property of their world like you know
things that emit sound and the effects
sounds have on things like our big part
of the show that's a cool you know area
to explore you know they've got these
like guns that shoot you know these
blasts of sonic energy and things like
that the way they also developed there I
guess they're aliens these alien
creatures is awesome and that leads
right into the practical effects they
use in the show cuz I was one of the
first things that struck me is they use
a ton of practical effects they look
awesome like you know is refreshing to
see that and especially if you're a fan
of effects there's some really cool
design work and you know some gooey
he you know Gore moments and stuff like
that you know we're having a
conversation right sure man you're just
like why not just like covered so much
of the review we don't want to give away
any spoilers know what where am I really
gonna go with this where am I really
gonna go this fortunately the show has a
lot more than just that let's see how I
did that I think the visual look of it
is fantastic Gale Anne Hurd one of the
producers of this show is also one of
the producers of The Walking Dead and
now you said there's the Terminator film
she's been involved with Tim oh yeah
she's been involved with a lot of stuff
but those are the two like big uns yeah
so mine she's really uh you know she has
a good track record I don't want to give
away any spoilers but they're here let
me I'm gonna see what they said on IMDb
is the plot to make sure I don't give
anything away the disappearance of a
decorated FBI agents wife leads into a
secret government unit assembled to hunt
a group of ruthless terrorists shadow
figures that may or may not be from this
world oh man no it's cool because it is
like it's like a show where they're like
hunting down terrorists but it looks
like there's some alien stuff involved
you know yeah and I like what Syfy does
in that regard because that's what
science fiction kind of does is takes
the world around and you know sort of
tries to explain it or tries to touch it
using these you know more heightened or
more metaphorical or more theoretical ya
know elements and and I like that
they're doing that and this in this show
takes time to do like social political
stuff as well you know they deal a lot
with it sonic the racism kind of becomes
like a theme in there too oh yeah and
it's an interesting approach you know
from the alien perspective it's a great
approach like even in the first episode
the villain of it gives like this speech
and it's in there doing a montage over
it and I was like this cool villain him
when they get to the second episode I'm
like this is a really good actor yeah
well there's some there's some strange
little nuances to his character that are
that are really cool and and they start
to make sense in a subtle way the main
character nathan phillips place Flynn at
first you know I was watching it with
you I
I was having a hard time like you know
really getting into his character but in
the second episode I was like you know
lemak he's got like a soft spoken voice
that can get tough you know way you know
there's something about it the way he
comes across where I'm like there's a
unique kind of charm to what he's doing
you know and this is like commitment to
the genre is really cool he's still you
know like the the lead in this kind of
TV series where he is kind of handsome
and rugged but you know he looks in the
most obvious but yeah in a little bit
more of a way that seems in a way that
seems a little more authentic and also
just like it fits this yeah world
exactly it's not you know you turn on a
lot of other like network tub and shows
you like wow these people are super sexy
yeah and they're doing this work where
I'm sort of just mostly following along
with the story here there's this other
character in there that you see in the
first episode that they're probably
gonna get more focused on her her name
is Regan Regan Regan Regan I don't want
to give anything away about her
character but if you just at least stick
her after the second episode she becomes
like that like you know I'm like that's
it that's a cool character to have in
the show oh yes you know like that's a
cool thing to have it is yet you guys
gonna watch you to find out what i mean
but it is it is something where I'm like
that's a female care drop that's I'm the
action part of the show as well yeah
that I can really get on board for well
yeah and the action see the thing that
this shows it kind of reminds me it has
the visual lustre of like a like a BBC
kind of a show but when it gets violent
you know like gets pretty pretty like
pulpy like yeah in a fun way I get this
this sense that Syfy's kind of embraced
the the sort of exploitation roots of
some of their original stuff in it and
have translated it really nicely yeah
because like it'll get when it gets
violent especially with it's like
practical effects yeah it gets violent
yeah yeah it doesn't hold back it shot
it like in a really cool way to yeah
they don't hold back on the violence
there are some moments where you're like
whoa yeah yeah yeah like especially
there's uh one gonna whisper t yeah yeah
I was a pretty well moment there are
times where it's like kind of scary you
know especially in the second there's a
really strong moment I remember
where I was like I was genuinely hooked
like that baby nepean yeah yeah yeah
well you know cuz it does kind of
combine all these things and and because
it's a cable show to they can kind of go
all out with certain stuff the whole
bedrock is this kind of sci-fi idea and
then when they're you know doing the
actual like procedural work you know
like going into fine things or
investigate like it gets kind of scary
and then the gore effects and stuff back
that up to oh yeah an action you know
pretty sweet yeah i mean the gore FX
play a big part too and a lot of the
action scenes and they have like those
guns that are like sonar whatever or
like yeah this shoot like like sound
black sound blast i want to use one of
those sound blast right now on my
neighbor downstairs because for some
reason they think it's cool to blast
your music
about to become a hunter something to
use the right context is no no the
show's got a lot of cool ideas you know
I like the cast and stuff like that and
over the first two episodes you can see
it's starting to dig in and take form so
you know there's there's enough that I
want to check out third one you early on
in a show you kind of just got to set
everything up and I think they finally
got their said yeah I feel like before I
was like I don't know where this shows
going and it seems kind of like is this
gonna be episodic or serial yeah and
then you know but the second episode
really shows like especially with the
way it ends I love the way the second
episode ended yeah this seems like the
kind of thing that could get really cool
over the Ozzie necessarily it opens up
to breathe yeah to see an improvement so
much from the first of the second
episode shows that these guys know how
to improve anyway guys yeah the first
episode has already premiered by the
time this video is out maybe the second
episode will have proved here make sure
to tune in on mondays ten nine central
on sci fi and you can visit their
official website sci-fi that's s YF y
dot com / hunters it's a very fantastic
show yeah mm-hmm it's pretty hot tastic
for this channel you can subscribe today
and become a reject John just play this
one's channel reasons to Jerry and this
that music in the background his theme
song a nice one knows how to turn off
his phone before filming a video you've
done that so many time um it's different
when I do it it is it is cuz your cuz
you're what what am I in control yes
that is what i was going forward and he
has dank ass dubs a podcast hosted by
his voice app on his phone again always
always you know combined with the phone
and that music outside i think the phone
is actually louder because it's right
here is that interesting relativity yes
an interesting scientific concept yeah
it's very good it's profound oh there
goes again turn that's okay let's cut
the camera no I'm gonna make sure
everybody knows
this [ __ ] is off we're not filming
another video after this we could turn
off the camera